okay let's see who else we got a lot of
these are for Jenna for editing requests
literally 50 people emailed us about
editing her podcast what is a podcast
you know how when we did a podcast with
her blog she blogged sorry sir they need
she needs somebody to edit her vlogs for
her and a lot of people a lot of our
fanbase are offering their services
because they're awesome people so we've
answered a question similar to this yeah
you just ate some paper spit out that
you ate paper oh my god he just did he I
thought those I know he ate the paper of
the of the sandwich so good even the
paper it's delicious proof the papers
yeah everybody that's ever been on the
show have said to me that your fans the
tiger belly fans aren't the most French
for fanatic fanatic yeah and loyal do
you're the greatest you guys are the
greatest people I'm so proud that you
were part of each other I love you guys
so [ __ ] much thank you so much big
hey Tiger belly crew I live with my
parents I'm a tall asian young guy fresh
out of high school I'm still a virgin in
19 and I want to lose it
hey man I'm tall hey man I'm tall not
extremely not extremely handsome but I'm
really handsome oh wow
we're gonna choke be careful I'm tall
not extremely handsome but I'm really
handsome I've been told I look like
Daniel Henney I know we're a fact I can
get girls no questions but I have no car
and no girl wants to date a loser with
no car what am I supposed to do bike to
her house lame my dad is too lazy to
teach me how there's a lot of
parentheses here hold on my dad is too
lazy to teach me how to drive so Kenny
my driver's license is slow I have no
privacy whatsoever at home
how can I get a GF with no
transportation your night mean it you're
gonna get it later
I didn't get post since I was 23 I'm on
TV show so I should talk differently no
yes I can't I I didn't get it I didn't
get ladies until I was 23 a gal until
yes so what I'm saying is that you know
when you get in the rhythm of that you
win it's gonna be great
it's not gonna go away unless you get in
a car accident you get paralyzed from
the neck down you better get that [ __ ]
today bought my point that bicycle is
gonna roll over to your crush's house
and that BMX but what I'm saying to you
is this is that home oh he's asleep he's
bones fall asleep I think papa has
departed do commercials
Spotify no yes
Spotify read the details
[Music]